♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW."
WE'RE JUST 23 DAYS AWAY FROM THE
MIDTERMS, AND DEMOCRATS ARE
HOPING BIG NAMES WILL HELP THEM
GAIN MOMENTUM INTO NOVEMBER.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA, FOR
EXAMPLE, IS HEADING TO
BATTLEGROUND STATES TO CAMPAIGN.
AND IT'S NOT PRESIDENT BIDEN OR
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS DEMOCRATS
REPORTEDLY WANT.
THEY WANT TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY PETE BUTTIGIEG TO
CAMPAIGN FOR THEM.
AND LOOKING AT NEW YORK'S
GOVERNOR'S RACE, THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS AVERAGE SHOWS THE RACE
BETWEEN GOVERNOR HOCHUL AND
CONGRESSMAN ZELDIN IS NOW A
TOSS-UP.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN 15 YEARS
SINCE NEW YORK HAS HAD A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR.
HERE'S ZELDIN ON "SUNDAY MORNING
FUTURES."
>> NEW YORKERS ARE LEAVING THIS
COUNTRY -- THIS STATE MORE THAN
ANY OTHER STATE ACROSS THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, AND PEOPLE WANT
TO SAVE THE STATE.
THEY WANT TO SAVE NEW YORK CITY,
AND THEY'RE TIRED OF HAVING TO
WAKE UP EVERY MORNING AND READ
ALL OF THE HEADLINES OF RISING
CRIME IN THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOOD,
PLACES WHERE THEY USED TO FEEL
SAFE AND WALK THE STREETS
COMFORTABLY AND NOW THEY'RE
CALLING AN UBER JUST TO GO A
COUPLE BLOCKS.
>> CHARLIE, LET'S START WITH THE
DEMOCRATS ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
THEY DON'T WANT THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OR VICE PRESIDENT,
THEY WANT THE TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY?
>> YEAH, THAT TELLS YOU --
THAT'S A PERFECT ENCAPSULATION
IN A NUTSHELL.
IT'S NO LONGER ABOUT DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, CONSERVATIVE OR
LIBERAL OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
DEMOCRATS, OBVIOUSLY, HAVE
FAMILIES THAT THEY HAVE TO FEED.
INDEPENDENTS HAVE TO GAS UP.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER YOUR SKIN
COLOR, YOUR GENDER, YOUR
RELIGIOUS BACKGROUND OR
WHATEVER, THIS MISERY AFFECTS
EVERYBODY PRETTY EQUALLY HERE.
AND THIS IS THE KIND OF -- AND
THEN YOU ADD INTO IT SOMETHING
LIKE CRIME WHICH YOU'RE SEEING
IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK, AND
SUDDENLY, YOU KNOW, A STATE LIKE
NEW YORK WHICH IS AS DYED BLUE
AS YOU CAN GET BECOMES IN PLAY.
AND I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND AFTER NOVEMBER, WE'RE GOING
TO FIND THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
STATES OR AREAS THAT WE NEVER
WOULD HAVE GUESSED THAT ARE IN
PLAY ARE GOING TO SUDDENLY BE IN
PLAY.
>> YOU BRING UP A GOOD POINT.
AND, NICOLE, PICKING UP ON WHAT
CHARLIE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE,
THE CRIME ISSUE, AND WE'RE ALSO
WATCHING GOVERNOR'S RACE TIGHTEN
IN A WAY THAT I DON'T THINK
REPUBLICANS WERE EXPECTING
EITHER.
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
BUT THESE ARE THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE DEMOCRATIC RHETORIC,
THEIR LACK OF IMMIGRATION
POLICY, THEIR SOFT ON CRIME
POLICIES BECAUSE IT HAS LED TO
COMPLETE LAWLESSNESS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AND ZELDIN IS MAKING A HUGE
POINT IN THAT HE IS PROMISING TO
FIRE NEW YORK CITY'S SOFT ON
CRIME D.A., HE IS SAYING THIS
GUY HAS TO GO.
WE HAVE TO PROSECUTE AND PUNISH
THE PEOPLE WHO, YOU KNOW, COMMIT
THESE CRIMINAL ACTS, BE TOUGHER
ON CRIME.
HE'S BEEN A VICTIM OF CRIME.
IT'S HAPPENED TO HIM
INDIVIDUALLY, HIS CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN AROUND, YOU KNOW,
SHOOTINGS, ONE DAUGHTER LANDED
30 FEET FROM A BULLET.
HE SEES IT.
AND ANYONE WHO WENT TERRIFIED
WITH THE CRIME IN OUR COUNTRY,
IT JUST MEANS YOU'RE IN SUB YOU
ARE GRAB. -- SUBURBIA.
EVERYONE'S GOING TO BE AFFECTED
BY IT.
THE FIRST THING IS TO BE TOUGHER
ON CRIME, AND THAT'S WHAT
ZELDINEN PROMISES TO DO, AND
VOTERS ARE TAKING NOTICE.
>> LET'S MOVE NOW TO
PENNSYLVANIA AND THE SENATE RACE
THERE BECAUSE FORMER PRESIDENT
OBAMA RECENTLY SAID THIS ABOUT
THE DEMOCRAT, JOHN FETTERMAN.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> COMES OFF AS A REGULAR GUY.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE HE SAYS
SOMETHING THAT IS A LITTLE, YOU
KNOW, OFF SCRIPT, AND THAT'S A
GOOD THING.
THAT'S A HEALTHY HIPPING, RIGHT?
-- THING, RIGHT?
AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT,
YEAH, EVERY CANDIDATE HAS TO BE
THEMSELVES.
FINISH.
>> OKAY.
SO, TYRUS --
[LAUGHTER]
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA, HE WON
PENNSYLVANIA TWICE, RIGHT?
SO HE'S --
>> YES, HE DID.
>> HE HAS SOME SAY IN WHAT FOLKS
WANT DOWN THERE.
BUT A REGULAR GUY.
>> YEAH.
COULD YOU IMAGINE --
>> DON'T GET SO MAD.
>> DAM MICHIGAN THE BEST THING
YOU CAN SAY ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO'S
RUNNING FOR OFFICE, HE'S A
REGULAR GUY.
SOMETIMES HE SAYS THINGS OFF THE
SCRIPT --
[LAUGHTER]
DO WE START THE SLOW CLAP?
THIS GUY GETS IT.
I THINK HE, I WILL GIVE HIM
CREDIT THAT AT LEAST HE'S,
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS NOT WILLING
TO EXPAND AND PUT FALSEHOODS OUT
ABOUT THESE CANDIDATES, AND HE
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT ONGOLDER --
ONBOARD, AND HE'S BASICALLY
DOING A SOLID FOR THE PARTY.
AMERICA'S NOT LOOKING FOR PARTY,
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR DEEDS.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO YOU
BRING OUT.
YOU COULD HAVE A HOLOGRAM OF JFK
COME OUT AND READ YOU SOME OF
HIS GREAT SPEECHES.
IT'S NOT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO AMERICANS RIGHT
NOW.
WHO YOU BRING TO THE DANCE TO
TRY TO GET VOTES, PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT THE MEAT AND POTATO
ISSUES.
WE'RE GETTING BACK TO REAL WORLD
TO PROBLEMS BECAUSE WE ARE FACED
WITH THEM.
WE CAN'T VOTE BASED OFF OF HOW
WE FEEL, I ELECTED THIS PERSON
AND THIS PERSON.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO WHO'S ON
POINT, ON TASK FOR WHAT NEEDS IF
TO BE DONE.
AND THE ONLY ONES RIGHT NOW WHO
ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
STRIKING A CHORD WITH AMERICANS,
WHAT STRIKES CHORDS WITH ME ARE
REPUBLICANS.
BUT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHEN YOU GET THE OPPORTUNITY,
WHEN YOU GET THE VOTE, YOU HAVE
TO DELIVER.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU CAN'T JUST SAY, HEY,
REPUBLICANS, WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS AND THEN GET IN AND GO BACK
TO BUSINESS, POLITICS AS USUAL.
WE'RE SEEING WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
THIS COUNTRY.
HE'S A ARE REGULAR GUY WHO HAD A
STROKE.
I'M SORRY HE HAD A STROKE, BUT
THE BEST THING YOU CAN SAY ABOUT
HIM HE'S A REGULAR GUY, NOW HE
HAD A STROKE, HE'S UNFIT.
AND THAT'S NOT AGAINST -- THAT
WOULD BE ME.
I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO -- BUT
THEY, IT'S SUCH A SELFISH PARTY.
WHY NOT HAVE SOMEBODY IN HIS
PARTY STEP UP AND RUN FOR HIM
WHO?
AND HE HAS A STROKE BEFORE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
>> YES.
>> AND HE LIED TO PEOPLE AT THE
TIME.
HIS CAMPAIGN LIEED ABOUT IT.
IF THEY WANTED TO PICK A
CANDIDATE WHO HAD NOT HAD THIS
HORRIBLE, UNFORTUNATE E EPISODE
OCCUR, THEN THERE WAS TIME TO DO
THAT BEFORE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
>> HE COULD TAKE HIS TIME TO
HEAL, GET HIMSELF RIGHT AND COME
BACK IN THE NEXT ELECTION IF IT
WAS ABOUT THE